hello everyone welcome to another
episode of history of science and
technology q a
so i'm happy to try and answer whatever
questions i can about either history
that i've personally been involved in
or more ancient history that i might
know something about about uh
areas of science that i know about and
areas of technology that i might know
about and i see we have a number of
questions that were left over from last
time
there's one question about uh stan ulam
and cellular automata and there's a
movie that just recently came out that
has the same title as uh autobiography
that stanley lam wrote called adventures
of a mathematician and i did my homework
and i watched the movie
um
and uh
i don't know everybody has different
preferences in movies um i i i thought
um this one i i found let's say i found
it interesting um i it was um
in terms of pure theatrical value
there's always a trade-off you know some
movies are accurate some movies are
uh of high entertainment value uh i
would suspect this one is more on the
accuracy side
um although it did bother me that in
this movie the uh the one of the big
characters in the movie was john von
neumann and the actor who was playing
john von neumann just looked nothing
like john von neumann
and so that probably to most people it
wouldn't make any difference but that
sort of bothered me and i think um
the uh
so i i mean i knew stan ulam
in the last couple of years of his life
and um maybe i can comment a little bit
on the history such as i know it
uh
both of cellular automata and of uh of
standalone
so
you know the idea of cellular automata
that you have some grid of cells and
each cell is black or white and then you
have some local rule and so on that idea
um has arisen many times i mean i've
been sort of waiting for somebody to
unearth a piece of babylonian you know
babylonian tablet that has a cellular
automaton on it that hasn't happened
i don't think it could not i think it's
perfectly possible that could happen in
fact one thing i saw just recently was a
an interesting babylonian tablet
uh that had various maze designs on it i
think it had eight different maze
designs there's one particular maze
design
that is really a very common maze design
which is variously said to be the plan
of the um maze of the minotaur and
knossos on crete you know designed by
daedalus it's otherwise said to be the
logo of the city of troy
it's said to be you know the pattern of
the walls of the city of troy it's it's
said to be many things but it's a
particular maze pattern that is one of
many possible combinatorial
possibilities and it shows up in many
places it shows up in the cathedral and
chartres it shows up in just all sorts
of places uh not clear completely what
its origin is and you see it on a lot of
coinage you see it on a lot of
coinage from crete particularly um
the this particular maze pattern so the
thing i found interesting was there's a
tablet that was discovered fairly
recently i think that has multiple
different maze patterns on it including
i think the famous one
but it's kind of an enumeration of
possible combinatorial patterns and that
makes one feel like you know the
babylonians were really close to having
cellular automata but i don't think they
had them
and um this whole question about
this phenomenon that is a big piece of
things i've studied of you know simple
rules complicated behavior there's so
many near-misses to that idea over the
course of history
but any case
the um the thing that john von neumann
got interested in
must have been 1946
7 that kind of time frame so so the
history there was that that um
uh john von neumann was a
originally hungarian
uh
mathematician
who um
came to the u.s
and had a series of uh really worked on
mathematical logic he worked on trying
to give a kind of a formal description
of quantum mechanics
he was sort of in very much the right
place at the right time and i think he
always felt
that he should have discovered girl's
theorem but he didn't but as soon as he
kind of heard girdle present girdle's
theorem he got it immediately and i
think the story of john von neumann in
many ways was a story of he was a very
quick person everybody says he was he
was like you know the quickest person
they they met and he had very broad
knowledge of lots of kinds of things
also very a very cheerful fellow
apparently um and uh he um
uh but he tended
i think
to be a little bit light on the deep
thinking side i mean he tended to be a
great problem solver and not necessarily
dig all the way down to you know what
was the fundamental point
and but he was a good enough problem
solver that you know he managed to
produce sort of elegant uh
uh or at least you know good
mathematical structures these problems
so the formulation of quantum mechanics
etc then
later on he got involved with electronic
computers
um he was um
a um
he was responsible for an important
report that got written
for the aniak
um about uh must have been 1946 i would
guess about sort of how to program the
eniac and sort of how you think about
applying ideas for mathematics and logic
to the problem of computer programming
and he really pushed
the idea of procedural programming i
think eckhart and mortally the people
who built the aniak were also involved
in this
but um uh the um uh you know this idea
of kind of procedural programming was
was a very you know it is it is probably
rightly called sort of a von neumann
style of of programming although that
also has tended to mean the sequential
processing idea but this idea of of you
know there are registers you store
things in them that was very much the
design of the machine and that was the
design of what what von neumann kind of
specified for that
and there's a little there's a few you
know if we read what he wrote there are
a few little little
pieces of elegant swords play about kind
of more theoretical aspects of logic um
that uh but it's it's mostly a a pretty
you know sort of what to me today looks
like a rather pedestrian kind of
procedural programming idea based very
strongly on the actual hardware of those
machines
um and also famously uh you know he he
made some
i would say
you know some guesses which didn't turn
out very good like for example he
imagined that nobody would ever write a
program longer than i don't remember how
many lines it was you know 200 lines
long or something and and basically why
did he say that well because he was
thinking about mathematical theorems and
people don't write theorems longer than
that but but he hadn't thought of
somehow i think kind of the idea of
subroutines
which in a sense you should have been
able to think of from the idea of
formulas because there are after all you
know i'm sorry theorems because you know
one theorem uses other theorems and that
allows you to have a much bigger kind of
you know you've got these sub theorems
so to speak just as you have sub
programs uh he also i think was
responsible for the claim that the us
were made to ibm i think that the us
would never have a need for more than
five computers which was again a a
you know it was a it was based on a sort
of a cognitive model at the time
um
that uh well uh you know who knows maybe
in the in the world of the future if the
pendulum swings towards cloud computing
enough maybe they'll only be you know
maybe at some level it's like declare
victory by saying they're only end uh
you know cloud providers in in the us or
something
but you know
he did a lot of things like in 1950 he
started looking at
numerical weather forecasting um using
computers to do weather forecasting i
don't think it was clear to him at the
time how difficult or easy that would be
it was a reasonable thing to try
um
the i certainly when
i would say that one of the things so i
worked at the institute for advanced
study in princeton for a few years in
the early 1980s
and at that time there were uh still a
few people kind of left over from the
days of of when von neumann had been
there and when he had built this
so-called joniac computer that was the
um uh the computer that um uh
sort of the the an iteration on the
eniac that was built at the institute
for advanced study and the
the story partially and i think um sort
of a little bit simplified story was
that when von neumann died the
mathematicians at the institute who'd
never been very keen on this idea of a
uh you know a nasty actual physical
computery thing that had sort of just
been very happy to accept the offer from
from thomas watson of you know i'll just
send a truck and take it over to ibm
which was then in in downtown uh new
york
um and uh that's the you know get take
the computer out of there
a friend of mine a few years ago when
the building was being demolished um a
friend of mine who's a i guess maybe a
trustee or something of the institute
now um had arranged to get the on off
switch of the computer that had been
bolted to the wall of this building that
was then being demolished
got it as kind of a collector's artifact
so to speak
but any case
back to um
von neumann and so on so for neumann
have been interested in
uh sort of got interested in computers
through being sort of brought in as a
consultant for that was also interested
in brains and how brains work
and kind of
uh
was
was concerned with this question of sort
of what's the what's the kind of common
thread between brains and machines in
fact the last book that von neumann
wrote
um which was
i think based on lectures he gave at
cornell um what were they called the
something the the machine and the brain
or something that the
it was a time it was the 1950s it was a
time
when
uh the whole idea of of sort of uh
giant electronic brains
were sort of coming on the scene
um in in kind of public awareness
and also
where
people
from a we're thinking about that in a
more theoretical way i mean one of the
fundamental things to realize is nobody
had any idea how hard it would be or not
to make an artificial brain
i mean it's just not obvious people
didn't know how hard it would be to do
weather prediction
people didn't know you know some things
turned out to be hard some things turned
out to be easy
um you know people uh and and so there
was a lot of
energy in the in the by the mid 1950s in
you know the term artificial
intelligence had been invented i think
by john mccarthy um
and uh there were sort of a gaggle of
people around mit called shannon marvin
minsky john mccarthy
uh um
uh
my gosh um uh jerry latvin
um these were these were people who were
interested in the sort of artificial
intelligence idea that had been a little
bit of the sort of an outgrowth of
warren mcculloch and walter pitts
who had been who had come from
the more
uh psychology psychiatry side of things
um trying to make sort of a mathematical
model of the brain and they had made in
the in the 1940s um this kind of this
early neural net mcculloch pitts network
early neural net model and that was sort
of growing up into these things that
were
being thought of in
well really the connection between
turing machines and neural nets these
were sort of for a while those were sort
of the two running
most common sort of ways of thinking
about models of computation were were
were neural nets and turing machines and
then somewhere in the middle of that
finite automata came in lambda calculus
uh was sort of a more theoretical and
recursive functions were sort of a more
theoretical more mathematical side of
things um than those two
okay so into the middle of all that von
neumann was interested in brains and
computers and so on and then also got
interested in the theory of biology and
the question of
could you
could you could you mathematicize
biology i mean in a sense von neumann's
uh sort of life activity had been
mathematicizing things whether it's
mathematicizing quantum mechanics
uh he did things in metallurgy he did
things in a bunch of different areas
kind of uh you know he was sort of a a
mathematician a person who would come
and mathematicize different areas
so biology was one of his targets and
the question was how would you make a
mathematical model of a biological
system
and his original idea was to have some
kind of thing where a biological system
was kind of like a factory it has all of
these it makes all these different
chemicals it does all these different
things and he was imagining something
that was uh i mean von neumann
um i guess in the in the in the distant
past have been trained as a chemical
engineer i think that was the the first
part of his his uh educational path
and so his kind of first sort of
instinct about biology was it's a giant
sort of self-running chemical
engineering factory
and i think then
if i remember the history correctly
oscar morgenstern
who was
later john von neumann's big
collaborator in theory of games his work
on game theory and uh
for economics and international
relations and so on and i think oscar
morgenstern's kids had a meccano set
kind of a lego set of its slightly
earlier time um and uh
kind of looking at that von neumann kind
of got the idea well maybe instead of
using the kind of differential equations
that would describe this giant chemical
factory maybe you could think about it
more as biology as being more like a
meccano-like thing
with uh kind of
built from these slightly more discrete
components
meanwhile stan ulam
had been
stan alam had been kind of a
a
discrete math enthusiast he had
grown up in levive what was then in
poland uh
then spelt i i can't say these words
properly it was then spelt lwow it's now
spelt lviv
and it's it's now in ukraine um but it
was then in poland um
and uh
that's a place where
for
uh who knows what reason there was sort
of a collection of mathematicians and
particularly discrete mathematicians
there ended up being this thing i wonder
if it still exists called the scottish
cafe
which was um uh some kind of cafe where
in in la viv where where they would um
uh people would write down these math
problems and they had sort of a book
that would hang out in the cafe where
math problems would get written down and
somebody else would would look at them
maybe i don't know whether they wrote
the solutions years later or not um but
any case that was uh sort of um
ulam's origin had been um in uh
in that sort of environment
and um he uh
uh
uh
and one of the things he'd worked on was
infinite matrices
so you know two-dimensional arrays
numbers but infinite in size
and so
he suggested to john von neumann that
that would be a good sort of additional
idealization
beyond kind of the idealization of um of
the meccano set type thing and so von
neumann started looking at
kind of then these two-dimensional grids
and sort of discrete states in the
two-dimensional grids bon neumann then
uh
kind of had the idea well how would you
then make a model of a biological cell
for example within that framework and he
thought well biological cells are
complicated and he made this very
elaborate kind of engineering model of a
thing with i don't know
um 29 states and i don't remember how
how many things and they ended up being
this 26 000 cell configuration
which by extending arms and copying this
and doing that and doing the other could
reproduce itself
okay and um
so and that was a construction that boy
neiman made uh very late in his life he
died in
1957 i guess
um
and uh he um uh he had done that
so he was he was kind of constructing
something he thought self-reproduction
was kind of a key feature of biology i
guess by the time he finished that uh
sort of the function of dna had been
discovered but i don't i think he may
have been uh too sick by that time to
have been sort of actively engaged in in
that type of um uh in that type of work
because i don't think he knew about
kind of uh digital information and dna
at the time when he was
thinking about sort of what would be the
the the computational architecture and
effect of biology
but um i mean marvin minsky told me okay
so so one of the things obviously i
discovered years later is that you don't
need a complicated cellular automaton to
end up getting you know very complicated
behavior that had also been seen and
other things like game of life and so on
had seen some some aspects of that as
well but it became really clear from the
stuff that i was doing in the early
1980s
and so then i was curious what did
people like von neumann think about the
question of why they needed such an
unbelievably complicated system to
achieve something like biology
and
so marvin minsky ai pioneer at mit
um had had known
john von neumann marvin was a graduate
student in mathematics actually at
princeton uh where where von neumann was
although marvin at the time had written
a thesis about neural nets as it turns
out um but um
so i asked marvin if he'd ever asked
john von neumann about this question of
you know was it
uh you know did you need complexity to
make complexity so to speak
and uh marvin claimed that he'd sort of
asked such similar questions and that
sort of von neumann had just been kind
of like well of course you you kind of
need that type thing you know how could
you get this such a complicated thing
out i don't know marvin wasn't not
always the most accurate uh purveyor of
historical stories um but that was uh
that's a data point at least but anyway
then
um
so
von neumann constructed this immensely
complicated self-reducing automaton
he then there was a person called arthur
burks
who had been one of von neumann's
assistants at the institute of advanced
study along with a person called julian
bigelow and maybe a couple of other
people
who
were working on the early computer
project and so on herman goldstein was
another one
herman goldstein went to ibm uh julian
bigelow stayed at the institute and
actually was still there when when i was
at the institute in the early 80s
um
and arthur burks
somewhat amusingly i did talk to him
about this um sort of said uh this
computer stuff it's going to blow over i
want to do something long-term i'm going
to go into philosophy and he became a
philosophy professor at university of
michigan um although he was also
responsible for
uh some things like i think he he was
probably responsible for bringing john
holland sort of pioneer of genetic
programming and things to the university
of michigan
and um there was sort of a whole whole
chain of of related people there but but
arthur burks kind of went more into
philosophy than into the practicalities
of computing but one of the things he
did was to finish von neumann's book on
the theory of self-reproducing automata
he also made another contribution to the
whole uh business by naming cellular
automata cellular automata
but von neumann
so that was kind of what what von
neumann
um
uh
did in this area
constructed this immensely complicated
kind of engineering construction
um and and arthur burks finished that
book
and that was by then i don't know
probably got finished in the early 60s i
would guess
meanwhile stan ulam
had
been mostly los alamos i think he was at
university of southern california for a
little while maybe he was university of
colorado if i'm remembered correctly for
a while too
but had been at los alamos a bunch
one feature of being at los alamos was
that there were electronic computers
there
i think there was a machine called the
maniac there if i remember correctly in
any case there were machines even in the
1950s there were
uh
you know digital computers available at
los alamos
um and they were being used
clearly in the um the
the early use of well at first human
computers and the electronic computers
human computers together with you know
mechanical computing devices had been
for calculating features of of the early
nuclear weapon
systems and so on and
that kind of continued uh to be an
important thing to do to calculate to do
these calculations um you know the
famous one famous calculation that had
to be done which was long before the era
of electronic computers the dura in the
first um
uh
nuclear explosion test in 1945 um the uh
you know the question was would
detonating a nuclear weapon
in or having a nuclear explosion in the
earth's atmosphere ignite the atmosphere
and cause
all of the uh you know start a kind of
chain reaction that would do something
like you know uh make everything turn
into nitrous oxide or something like
that and that was a a a late stage
calculation that somebody did that no it
probably wouldn't happen
and uh so so they decided to go ahead
and do the test uh
do the tests on the basis of that not
happening but in any case computing had
been an important thing um at los alamos
and uh one feature of the computers
there was that sort of computers were in
sufficiently plentiful supply that you
could use them to do kind of random
experiments on
and so
um
stan ulam together with
um shrant richard shrant maybe
did
a few experiments on cellular
automaton-like things
this is probably in the 50s in the 1950s
and
ended up looking at some slightly
generalized
um
somewhat zero one two-dimensional
cellular automata and making patterns
from them also actually tried to make a
three-dimensional cellular automaton
pattern and had a had a structure
constructed out of wooden blocks that
they photographed and things those
papers i don't think ever got sort of
published in journals i think they were
internal reports at los alamos
i certainly saw them years later
i think stan ulam and some of those
other guys
were talking about
a potential field called orcsology which
was some kind of thing to do with the
study of growth
and the study of how things should i
don't know what does oxology it must
come from a greek and a greek word and
i'm not um remembering what that
might it must be the same word same word
root as the as the root for auxin which
is a plant hormone so i don't know
exactly what that must be some kind of
extension and growth type word in greek
but anyway that was a thing that that
they were interested at that time and
they did a little bit of work on that
that was around the same time that the
fermi pasta ulam experiment got done
that was also done at los alamos
mid-1950s and that was a
an experiment where the question was
i think a question asked by enrico fermi
um was if you have a bunch of springs
and weights attached to them you have a
whole chain of these things just
starting going if they are harmonic
oscillators if they're linear springs
then we kind of know what happens and we
can use fourier analysis to say there
are certain modes of the thing and it
all behaves in a simple way the question
was if you're trying to understand
thermodynamic equilibrium and you're
trying to understand how does one go
from
something that has some
uh
the um um
um
uh how does one um how does one go from
from something where there are just uh
uh
sort of individual modes excited in this
collection of springs to something where
energy has been spread among many modes
and so the idea was well let's add some
non-linearity to these springs
and when you do that you can no longer
do the kind of fourier analysis
calculation and so what those guys
realized is well you could actually
compute it on a computer and so they did
and
they noticed that
there was a spreading of energy between
the different modes but there were these
weird things where there was sort of it
took a lot longer to spread the energy
than one might have thought and that was
one of the
several discoveries of the phenomenon of
solitons solitary waves um was made
there but that was another kind of piece
of the kind of tradition of doing sort
of exploratory uh computational work at
los alamos at that time i should say
that there was a little bit of
exploratory work that got done even on
the on the institute for advanced study
computer um for example people have been
interested in computing the digits of
the square root of two to see whether
there will be regularities in them
things like that
um but in any case the the um
uh ulam
uh
you know he worked on this in the 1950s
i guess on these early cellular automata
and then to my knowledge he did nothing
more on them
um and then i met him in probably 19 by
we had a conference at los alamos i was
a consultant at los alamos
um in their
theoretical division
uh starting probably in 81 something
like that 82
and um as a result of that
uh organized this conference after i
started working on cellular automata i
thought be cool to organize a conference
about it and and
somehow that got done at los alamos um
and along with a couple of other people
and some help from the los alamos kind
of um uh yeah theory theory division uh
uh
sort of management uh we organized this
conference it was kind of a fun
conference because
cellular automata was something that had
been worked on in various disparate
places
and
uh
by many different names they were called
tessellation automata
homogeneous structures
um
what's the name in in um
oh my
uh
there was a name
um
automorphisms of the shift is one but
not automorphisms um
uh i forget that there are a bunch of
other names um
from very different origins forests of
stunted trees was another cellular
thomas thing but i had tracked all this
stuff down um because i was trying to
understand the history of of the field i
mean one of the things that had happened
was essentially everything that had been
done had been done in two-dimensional uh
grids
and and in many cases the the rules had
gotten a bit more ornate
and and
um stan hold on actually had thought
about the one-dimensional case
and had convinced himself that it
couldn't be interesting and that the
only way to make it interesting was to
have some complicated long-range rule
type thing
so you know he didn't do those
experiments again the experiments that i
ended up doing in the early 80s would
have been actually very easy to do
on the computers at los alamos in the
1950s but but they weren't done
um so
in any case the uh uh this conference in
1983 was kind of fun because i invited
kind of uh all the people who'd ever
written about
these things that were equivalent to
cellular automata and it's just an
interesting collection of people um that
uh um that ended up coming and there's a
proceedings from that back from 1983 but
the after-dinner speaker um for that
conference that we organized was was
talking about kind of the the history of
of things like this los alamos and i
have to admit that i don't really
remember
i think it was not a terribly good
speech as far as i was concerned but i
don't actually remember a specific
content promoter a friend of mine
uh interviewed stan ulam a science
journalist interviewed stan alan and the
transcript of that interview exists and
maybe we should put it on the web at
some point it's kind of an interesting
interview in which um one of the more
notable things is you know well to you
guys you know today
john von neumann uh is just one of these
mathematicians of old like like gauss is
to stanulam but to stan john von neumann
is this jolly fellow he knew pretty well
um
but uh
in any case that that um
um now as far as some
um
you know
i didn't
know
directly about standing alone's work on
the manhattan project which is what this
question originally was was about i mean
i'd certainly heard of the tele-ulam
device
um
for
for thermonuclear uh
explosions but i um
wasn't uh didn't have specific knowledge
of that i mean it was a it was a very
notable thing back in the in the late
1970s early 1980s when i was involved in
in particle physics and so on that the
kind of the the the the uh the sort of
the the shadow of the manhattan project
was very much alive and well and and
there were many people who had had
distinguished roles in the manhattan
project
and who basically had been uh sort of uh
in a sense had whole careers that that
had been launched by their involvement
in the manhattan project and it was uh
surely a very um uh
a very impressive crowd um that uh uh
that figured out the things that had to
be figured out from you know dick
fineman who was who is in charge of the
human computers
um
uh
who were doing calculations because that
was before the during the manhattan
project was before electronic digital
electronic computers existed
um to uh
uh people like um
oh gosh there were there were all these
people some of them were still los
alamos when when in the early 80s like
nick metropolis inventor of the
metropolis algorithm for monte carlo
calculations
um people uh
uh just all sorts of different people
and it was always something where you
know in the days before the web you
couldn't go look up oh what did bob
bakker do in the manhattan project what
did so-and-so do in the manhattan
project but there were all these people
who were sort of highly placed in the
physics world who had been sort of
gotten their start through being young
people making contributions to the
manhattan project and a lot of that was
sort of still had seeded the field of
physics
um
let's see
um
okay there's a question here
from aaron
how do i approach studying the history
of technology to inform work on current
projects do you do very targeted studies
when starting a project how much
historical context is enough
you know
this is something that comes up both in
doing science and doing other things
um
i find it hard okay
usually a project starts with a question
or some objective
and then the first question is has it
already been answered do people already
know the answer to this do people
already know how to do this
there's a certain amount of
investigation there but often what you
find is
well doesn't look like people directly
address this
question there are things sort of around
it
that are sometimes quite
incomprehensible
um
because they require you know some whole
context that i don't have
um to understand
and
so then the question is how deeply do
you dive into that context and trying to
understand all of it and is it a good
idea or not and sometimes i think it's
it's kind of not such a good idea
because that context took a field to a
certain point
and it didn't get it to the point where
you wanted to get to
and there's a reason for that it got
stuck for some reason and part of the
reason might have been that context had
defined things in a certain way and it
kind of you can't get there from here
once you've defined things in that way
so if you dive deep into that context
you kind of cut yourself off from
wherever you know whatever the way you
have to go in this perhaps uh
more you know different direction
so anyway the i i think you know i tend
to do homework after the fact more than
perhaps homework before the fact once i
think i understand a bit more about how
something works
i then
i i guess i'm both interested in history
and i find i i i sort of feel an
obligation to understand the history um
i think uh
you know if you're an academic it's kind
of like let's just throw in some
references and then that's good that
that's that's what we need to do uh i
guess i have been actually interested in
the actual history of things which
requires a lot more work than just
you know throwing in sprinkling in the
references type thing and but i find it
interesting uh and and sometimes
understanding the history gives one an
idea about some some great new thing
that one can do i would say more often
it's just interesting just
intellectually interesting to see what
happened
intellectually interesting and relevant
for the next project to see how did they
miss that why didn't they do that well
can i learn something from the mistake
that was made in missing some particular
thing uh and and you know that sort of
gradually builds up over the course of
my life i suppose i've i've just seen a
huge number of examples of that of of
you know of situations where people like
it was very close and if they'd only
conceptualized it this way they would
have been able to to get further so to
speak and i i have to say i those kinds
of uh issues uh certainly i reflect on
those issues as i'm trying to do
projects and it's kind of like what
would uh you know
what would the thing that
where
am i stuck here in the same way that
field x was stuck
in 1945 or something or wherever it was
um and can i see my way through based on
knowing what happened in field x
um more so i would say methodologically
than in terms of specific content
and when it comes to uh well when it
comes to another thing worth saying is
that that sometimes there are old ideas
that
uh
in the new context that one has or the
new tools one has now those ideas can
actually turn into something
sometimes
there are
ideas well sometimes in in
some some places like in particular in i
don't know models of computation which
sort of uh somewhere between technology
and and science
uh you know you look at some of those
things it's like oh my gosh this is so
complicated
like von neumann self-reproducing
automaton oh my gosh this is so
complicated what can i learn from this
if anything you know or did they
you know is there a way to drill down
underneath all of this complexity of
models and find sort of an essential
thing underneath or is it all just tied
up with the complexity of this model and
there's really not much underneath and
so it you know i've seen it go both ways
um
aaron is asking is there a list
of history of science and technology
books that i would recommend i don't
know i i kind of like there's a there's
a series there's a couple of books on
the history of the mathematical sciences
that i rather like nice summaries of
things i i tend to um
i suppose i'm i'm um
um
there are you know i i have a huge
number of historical scientific
biography books
and um uh you know you learn different
things from different books i mean
sometimes there'll be books written by
the person themselves an autobiography
sometimes i don't know i'm just
remembering i you know one random book i
have is some a book with the title lord
kelvin's early home
and it's written by the sister of uh
um william thompson lord kelvin um and
it's kind of a charming book i don't
know how much it tells one about sort of
the the uh uh the discovery of of i
don't know
features of of um of thermodynamics and
temperature and so on but it is it
paints a picture of a person and
sometimes or you know darcy thompson
uh his daughter wrote a biography of him
there are these kinds of um uh and a
different you know just just different
or you know serotouring wrote a
biography of her son alan turing um
these are things that
uh you know you see these different
books that have different angles there
may be a a
very for example
well ada lovelace for example who i
studied a bit um uh had had a variety of
biographers who had written in some
cases rather
rather
strange biographies but which were very
you know which had missed many points
and and concluded had many kind of axes
to grind i think
um that
and then
more recently some rather rather well
well-written things have been have been
written about ada lovelace um but in a
sense
there were
each of these things even if it's not a
very good biography um somehow
there are some things you can learn i
mean you have to
you have to kind of i think in some
cases
at least for me
there are cases where i kind of feel
like i can tell the person really did a
serious job of the history and they
didn't make a lot of mistakes and there
are cases where people just sort of
plucked a few threads from here and
there and knitted them together into a
giant sweater or something and um it
isn't uh um
uh and what comes out is has a little
relationship to um to the reality of
what went in and is is kind of a a more
like a sort of piece of historical
fiction than it is a piece of historical
biography
you know one of the things that i've
noticed from my efforts to do historical
biography one of the things
that i think people sometimes don't
understand
is in the end if you if you understand
enough everything makes sense
that is if you say how did ada lovelace
get to the point of doing this or that
thing that she did or how did so and so
how did ramanujan get to the point where
he did such and such a thing
these are things which if you drill long
enough you will understand at least
there are two things you need to do to
be able to understand this you need to
know something about how discoveries are
actually made and what it actually feels
like and how people act around the
process of making discoveries and one of
the things that's also true
is that many discoveries that get made
in in science technology and so on you
know the storybook version is you know
on this particular day an apple fell on
somebody's head and they had this
brilliant idea
okay that is never the real story the
real story is usually five years ten
years of you know context building of of
getting to the right place at the right
time so to speak and then maybe the
apple falls
and you know
that's uh that's the moment or people
often uh after the fact the people
themselves will kind of simplify the
story by saying you know
and and then the apple fell and then
everything got figured out
sometimes they don't even recognize that
for 10 years they were working in that
direction and that was just the you know
the sort of final moment where things
clicked but one of the things i've
noticed is that you know when when
something there are no
surprising jumps
when you peel everything back
you find out that there was a big long
process that led from here to there and
yes there was a particular idea a
particular day but it wasn't the giant
jump it was the final thing that you
know reached across to the other side of
the river type thing it wasn't it wasn't
uh you know the the bridge was already
largely built it was just the completion
so to speak and i noticed that even with
things i've done myself
i'm like uh you know oh it looks like
that just got figured out and you know i
must have figured that out just one day
and i i go back and look and i realized
well actually there's this whole long
history that caused me to think about
the right kinds of things in the right
kind of way at that particular time et
cetera et cetera et cetera it's never
that simple um but on the other hand it
always has an explanation and people
sometimes i think who who
you know write history from outside of
the kind of the experience of doing
science for instance have this idea that
people have these flashes of inspiration
and then everything is clear and it was
not clear before and that's just not how
it works and in all the efforts that
i've done a writing historical biography
that's you know you can always trace the
path there always is a path it's never a
jump
and it's you know it's a walking path
not a a giant jump from here to there
and it's just that's the nature of doing
hard things is that they tend you know
you have to build them up over over a
period of time
uh
question from spicy here
what was it about ancient greece that
allowed for great advances in math and
science and great thinkers
i don't know that history as well as i
might have done uh might do i mean i
think that um
the
the concept
uh i mean in in you know
athens
was a place
that
you know i mean its economy was largely
based on you know slaves do the work and
um uh then there are the athenian
citizens and they are um
uh kind of um
uh
you know
uh i i don't know whether they're uh you
know some of these people like you know
i don't know plato and so on was a i
think he owned vineyards and so on i
mean these are people who are who were
kind of uh sort of set up
in the um uh
in the kind of um
my impression at least is that they were
not
people who were sort of um uh
um
working in the salt mines so to speak
there were people who were who were uh
able to
uh lead a sort of upscale of the time
life now i don't know
you know one of the things that i find
interesting about sort of the
philosophers of old whether it's the you
know the epicurus or the democritus
or the um you know those various
pre-socratic philosophers and so on they
came from all different places around
kind of asia minor um and uh you know
the sort of greek um
connected world they weren't all from
athens
um but i you know that that's obviously
the the a big concentration was it was
in athens and i don't really know
the um uh the kind of um the the
sort of aspects of of of how that was
was working
i have the impression
that
um
well i mean the interest in in ancient
greece
was this kind of philosophical interest
of kind of the uh the uh
you know thinking about things from a an
abstract point of view
in babylonian times and and you know
that babylon was sort of the place
where a lot of kind of our modern ideas
about about math and and kind of those
kinds of things originated and the sense
that was driven i think by a very
practical thing which was they had
cities and as soon as you have a city
you have to kind of like organize things
you have to know like oh somebody owns
this plot of land somebody's going to
inherit this thing from that person
people are going to sell each other
things there's got to be standardized
weights and measures oh you've got to
have you know
a tax year and it's got to be you know
you've got to have calendars and all
this kind of thing all the structure was
very much a thing that came in in
babylon now in babylon one has the
impression at least based on what
survived that it was very practical it
was like you know the math exercises
which are quite hard even by today's
standards of you know uh x number of
people are digging a trench and the
trench will be this shape and they'd
shovel this number of things of dirt you
know how long will it take to make this
this weirdly shaped trench and so on
there are all sorts of problems one
still has from ancient babylon of that
of that type word problems of of ancient
mathematicians i mean well in those days
there were these scribal schools right
that taught i mean the big thing to
learn was could you learn to write make
these cuneiform wedges um on pieces of
clay and in the scribal schools they
would teach
uh sort of how to write but that came
bundled with learning math
and uh you know learning about things
you could write about
um
and so in babylon my impression is that
the you know it was not a very
philosophical in kind of place it was
more a place where it was like let's do
the math and work out how long it's
going to take you know to to plant this
field or to do whatever else one was
going to do
um and i think uh
in
you know in in greek times even in the
times of uh
people like failies heraclitus all these
kinds of people
um the kind of the idea of sort of how
do things work
and let's try and ask the question you
know how does the world actually work
um and that was a thing which i don't
think
you know the babylonian i think in the
epic of gilgamesh i think there's some
sort of how the world works
type things but they're pretty simple i
think that that you know they're they're
sort of creation myths as every as every
civilization has had but um i don't
think they're
they're particularly kind of um uh
complex thinking kinds of things and
that's something that seems to have
originated in in in greek times it's
something that um
um
was then
you know that was the kind of focus and
you know it kind of aristotle was kind
of the person who catalogued the most of
that stuff and his works were the thing
that things that from a thousand years
or so were kind of the
the sort of uh you know
uh
sort of other than the bible so to speak
where the kind of the um in the western
and western world were kind of the the
source of uh
kind of you know this is the this is the
encyclopedia of knowledge so to speak
um and i think that that uh uh
you know if you look at for example um
in the roman
civilization
there's again much less
sort of philosophical science so to
speak being done much less thinking
about how is the world fundamentally put
together i mean one exception is
lucretius from first century a.d
who was i think a greek connected um
uh
person although he wrote in latin um he
wrote this book called um de rerum
natura the on the nature of things
um which uh has one one of my favorite
um uh kind of uh conceptions from
antiquity about how the world works
you know the world is made of atoms he
said following democritus and the
gibberish and people like that um the
world is made of atoms and perhaps they
are arranged together to make the world
as
words are arranged together in sentences
according to the laws of grammar and i
think that's a nice i mean you know it's
written in a in poetry and it's it's a
very poetic version of a way to describe
a formal system where you have these
discrete elements and then you're you're
making something like a grammar that
describes how those elements go together
um
i'm not sure i have a there's probably
more to say about some uh you know one
question
um
a friend of mine named armando who's a
classics professor in oxford has written
about uh kind of the the concept of
innovation in ancient greece
and um i think one of the things he says
is that for in a lot of areas there
wasn't a lot of motivation to do
technological innovation because
basically there were people to do the
work
and i mean i i hate to draw the analogy
with modern times of manufacturing of uh
you know while you can still find
people to do the work why make a robotic
factory so to speak and the one place
where there really was technological
innovation was in things like siege
machines and i think alexander the great
was was big on that kind of stuff
technology for warfare was a place where
people uh needed to innovate and uh
because you know you you had to build
the bigger siege machine or whatever the
bigger thing to i don't know scale the
walls of some city or or try and uh
throw something over the walls or some
some such other thing
um but i think that that so there wasn't
as much technological innovation in
those days as
might have been
you know wasn't was not as as driven by
by those things as as it might have been
um
let's see
ah
gosh
i think i've talked about there was a
question from rbs here about ed freddie
and i think i've talked about ed before
here
um
so let me i'm happy to talk about ed and
um
uh
uh but i think i i think let me not
repeat myself there
um
let's see
okay rj is asking in 2001 a space
odyssey the alien monolith is said to be
a von neumann probe is it rectangular
because of the cellular thomas and
inspiration
so i think that conflates
several pieces of science fiction
history
i think
that
the concept okay
for people who are not um into this kind
of history of fictional science
uh 2001 a space odyssey was made in 1968
by stanley kubrick um
it happened to be for my personal
history it happened to be the first
movie i ever saw in a movie theater
so it's and i i was uh i wrote something
about it um oh a couple of years ago at
the 50th anniversary and i was because
i'm
archived nut i had actually saved i
guess i saw it in some kind of um
at a time in england when when um it was
sort of a just come out movie and it was
sort of the movie theater was
celebrating the it's just come out movie
um although i think it was a you know a
matinee of the movie and i was sort of
pretty much the only person in the movie
theater just some random whatever eight
nine year old kid or something those
were the days when you could just plunk
an eight nine year old kid in a movie
theater on their own and and that was uh
considered just fine um but in any case
the the um
uh you know they had a sort of program
for this thing which i which i had kept
and so i can precisely
uh you know reproduce the the you know
when i saw this movie all that kind of
thing but anyway the 2001 movie
um was based on a short story by arthur
c clarke
and i originally sort of was inspired by
that and then the i think the screenplay
was written by
by um uh
i think arthur c clarke was was much
involved in in writing the thing
um and then there was some
a book version of 2001
and if i'm not remembering wrong i think
the idea of that it was okay what what
first of all what was up online and
probe let me explain that
so
this idea of self-reducing automata
had
in in the 1950s
when you were thinking about what's the
really high-tech thing
that
we could
imagine doing
with
uh
with um
yeah 1950s right with with our devices
it's oh let's do something in space
let's have a self-reproducing factory on
the moon
and so this kind of the the cellular
automaton idea
of self-regressing whatever's quickly
segwayed into people writing about
self-reproducing factories on the moon
and this notion of a von neumann probe
was kind of the idea of well let's send
out self-reproducing spacecraft you know
forget about having and that's the way
we populate the galaxy and i thought it
was in the 2010 sequel to 2001
that the idea was added of having these
um of having just a giant collection of
these some of these uh black monoliths
and so on that eventually i don't know
uh maybe spoiler alert i think it turns
jupiter into a star or some such other
thing i forget um but uh it wasn't a
spoiler alert because i don't remember
the plot well enough
but any case the in in the original
2001 movie
the
the thing is
that
uh the concept is this is sort of first
contact with alien civilization
and the aliens have left this this
object which was critical to the history
of of
human development they've left this
object they've left a version of this
object on the moon
and the question is it was it was
called tma1 the tycho magnetic anomaly
and it was the the storyline i think was
that they you know detected this strange
magnetic
uh thing on the moon and uh the moon
doesn't have a magnetic field i don't
think that was known when that movie was
made whether the moon has a magnetic
field or not it doesn't um but uh this
was sort of the concept was there was
some magnetic thing buried uh near this
crater and um the the but that thing was
an artifact and the question is
cinematograph cinematographically
how do you represent the fact that a
thing on the moon is an artifact because
most of the moon is made of jagged you
know rocks et cetera et cetera et cetera
the concept was
it's a perfect
precise
cuboidal object and that perfection is
kind of what leads you to the concept
that this must have been something an
artifact it's kind of ironic that we
are so proud of our engineering and so
on and we're so you know we make such
such sophisticated things and yet the
way to show that it's a thing that's
made as a by by by some purpose
is to show that it's a a you know a
perfect geometrical form rather than
something much more complicated looking
like a rock it's it's kind of ironic
that that's the signature of
artifactness is that it's simpler than
what nature makes and that's that's
something that's interesting if one's
understanding sort of the origins of
complexity in the world
but um uh in that movie
it's kind of the uh you know i think it
has one to four to nine uh side ratios i
never checked that it actually is that
in the movie you never know in in uh you
know what guts get what gets changed for
for cinematographic effect
but um
the thing that um
uh
let's see i was going to say in that
movie there's a kind of a curious thing
in the in towards the end of the movie
um the uh
someone actually goes and kind of meets
the aliens so to speak or something like
that and there's a few frames it's sort
of an interesting sequence
where
there are these kind of flashing lights
and you see if you if you freeze the
frames you'll see that they're a bunch
of octahedra flashing octahedra they're
a bunch of geometrical forms and that's
kind of the the uh i think kubrick's
sort of way of signaling this is a you
know this is a an intentional
artifact-like thing as it's a
geometrical form like that
um so i i don't think there was a
connection between uh kind of the grids
of cellular automata and the um and the
the cuboid shape
of those of those um of those things i i
i don't know i i did interact a bit with
arthur c clarke
um
and i'm trying to remember
i have this vague recollection that he
wrote me a letter about something to do
with cellular automata um and so that he
was aware of those things but this is
much later this is this is now in the
probably
maybe 1980s maybe maybe much later than
that even
um so i'm i'm not quite sure i i can't
connect those those dots quite
um
someone is asking what is the book top
right of the horse's head do i have a a
a book
i'm not sure
hard to know
i think my my my books
circulate around i have about 8 000
books altogether i just did a
reorganization of books recently and the
ones here are
some that i'm reading currently and uh
or supposed to be reading currently and
then there's a bunch of books
sort of back that way that are about um
uh
um
uh
let's see closest to the camera
oh oh that's
that book it's called the conlanger's
lexapedia
um as it turns out it's not a book i've
i have to say that i've read
um that's a collection of books um
uh to do with a project that i'm hoping
to get started soon about what i call a
symbolic discourse language
um
the um
uh
that project has to do with
finding a way to represent
just us with wolfram language we've
we've
created a computational language which
can express many kinds of things about
the world
the idea of this sort of symbolic
discourse language is to be able to
express
other kinds of things about the world
including things about people mental
states and you know intentions and all
sorts of other kinds of things
and the kinds of things that you might
see in a piece of english text or in a
legal document which are not yet
representable in our computational
language and so i've been interested in
in kind of making a language in which i
can express things like i want to eat a
piece of chocolate
and um that
we can in
you know our language right now we can
express the piece of chocolate part
pretty well but the i want to eat part
we can't yet express
so i've been interested in in finding a
way to express those things
and there's kind of been a funny history
in this sort of notion of finding sort
of a symbolic language to represent
thought it's something that uh was quite
popular in the 1600s
um and uh it's kind of an unfinished
project from the 1600s
you know
leibniz
was um
uh
um
was was part of that
uh he had his characteristic universalis
his idea that you could convert
everything like all features of a legal
case into some kind of thing-like logic
and then be able to immediately decide
the case there were people like person
called john wilkins an english chap
who
had a book i'm sure i have a copy of it
there yes an essay towards a real
character and a philosophical language
that was his book
um
and uh
the goal was
to have a representation
of
exactly what i'm trying to do you know
representation of things in the world as
a symbolic language now now you know
they had somewhat confused things like
how the characters get written
with how the grammar works
with how the actual meaning works and so
on but in wilkins's book for instance
there's sort of catalogues of the
different kinds of things that exist in
the world a little bit like a thesaurus
might have a catalogue of concepts it
has a catalogue of things that that
exist in the world
and um the
um
it's um
uh the thing that
is
to me interesting about it is you look
at that catalog of things that exist in
the world and you say which of these are
the same today as they were then a lot
was the only thing is uh there's an
awful lot about the many ways to die
um and all sorts of terrible medical
conditions which which uh are not common
anymore that were you know well covered
in the things to know about life
um and obviously the the a big missing
area areas technology um but a lot of
the stuff in the middle about some uh
you know the way people lead their lives
it's the same in the 1600s as today
um but so this idea of sort of making it
what was it those days mostly called a
philosophical language a language that
could express things without
using in a kind of precise fashion
without using the specific words of a
human language that was a thing that was
also kind of related to the development
of mathematical notation things like
that leibniz was much involved in that
also
this idea of making kind of an
artificial language that would be kind
of a a better representation i mean i
think in in in the hands of leibniz the
the characteristic of universalis was
sort of a a connected to logic and
connected to mathematics
um although
i would say leibniz doesn't make as much
connection between logic and mathematics
as he might have done those were to him
for him you know mathematics was more
about algebra and so on and logic was
more about
uh kind of the the reasoning of things
and um uh wilkins i don't think was very
mathematical in what he did
um so
the idea of kind of
a a language to represent things that
kind of hung around for a long time and
when george boole was was working on
boolean algebra taking kind of logic and
making it mathematicizing it in the
1830s and so on um he uh his later book
was called laws of thought you know he
was imagining that sort of the boolean
algebra thing was kind of the the basis
for some sort of laws of thought
but but the thing that really happened
was
um
well okay so so one of the things that
happened in leibniz's time
is that latin had been the language of
scholarship
for
you know 2 000
close to 2000 years at that point
um
and uh no not quite as long as that 1500
years
um
and uh but at that time people were
starting to write
in the local languages french english
german
um
you know newton wrote his principia
mathematica in latin he wrote his optics
in english
only a few years later so to speak
so
it um uh one of the things that leibniz
was concerned with is okay is the
scientific enterprise the intellectual
enterprise is going to fragment because
nobody will be able to read each other's
stuff anymore because it's not all in
latin that was part of his motivation
for developing mathematical notation as
kind of an international notation that
would go across human
languages but that idea of how do you
sort of make a
um a kind of a non-language a
non-specific language language
it hung around i think the next time it
really emerged was in the late 1800s
there was some mathematical work done on
it term guseppi piano of the piano
axioms of arithmetic fame had a language
called interlingua which was a kind of
um a latin based language that was
intended to be
um
sort of a a a way of communicating
things beyond mathematics
in sort of precise in some kind of uh
non-non-human language specific way i'm
afraid in the end it's sort of a
cautionary tale because piano wrote some
of his books in interlingua and that
sort of definitely reduced his his uh
his readership by having it not only on
a subject that people found hard to
understand but also in a language that
people didn't know but around that time
um
uh there were other artificial languages
the most well-known being esperanto
developed by zamanov i guess in the
1880s
um and uh that language so esperanto is
a language which intended to have
simplified sort of normalized grammar
and syntax and so on it's a kind of a
based on some mixture of you know
spanish and polish and you know
italian and maybe english and french and
so on that that sort of general class of
languages um all mushed together to make
something which has had a sort of
simplified form i think the word
esperanto means i hope in in esperanto
and esperanto was seen as being
something which would among other things
sort of help bring peace to the world by
having people be able to sort of speak a
common language and i think there was a
sort of a complicated interplay between
kind of world peace type movements and
just we're trying to make an
international language type type things
and esperanto achieved a certain degree
of success over the period from i guess
1880s up until probably well probably
100 years basically i remember it used
to be the case if you went to like
london heathrow airport that you would
see you know signs for things in
different languages and my favorite was
always the signs in esperanto but
sometime in the 1980s i think they took
down those signs and um but in any case
the the the um this idea of artificial
human languages is an interesting one
sort of relates to the philosophical
languages idea in more recent times
there there are a number of these some
constructed languages conlangs um some
of those have been constructed for sort
of entertainment purposes you know
klingon for example or um there's a
language and
what is it called i'm afraid of this
this shows one of my one of my blind
spots in in in culture i never watched
television so i don't i don't know this
well but there's a language in game of
thrones um that uh oh something is krill
i don't remember what it's called but
anyway that that's another uh known
constructed language and um uh
so there's kind of a there's kind of a a
a strange community of people who do
language construction
there's a certain irony i suppose i
haven't i've always wanted to go to one
of these conlangers conventions but
there's a certain irony because you
bring together a bunch of people who've
all invented their own language and the
question is can they actually talk to
each other because their own languages
are all different it reminds me of a
thing i've i've thought for ages about
you know i've made a point of trying to
meet people who've who've invented uh
computer languages of various kinds and
i've thought oh wouldn't it be fun to
bring everybody together and i realized
no you know you know what everybody's
gonna be talking in their own language
basically
um not as much fun as you might think
but any case i think um uh so this kind
of conlang idea
and there are a variety of kinds of of
constructed languages from ones which
are essentially you know artworks to
ones which are intended to be
uh practical for some reason or another
they're kind of two extreme cases that
um uh
the um
um that i think are interesting end
points
um
uh one is the language called ethquil
uh constructed by john kiara and another
is a language called toki pona
constructed by sonia lang
and ethquil is the the language that has
everything in it
it's got you know i think um it's
creator sort of gone through the
languages of of that humans speak and
tried to find all the different tenses
that get used all the different cases
that get used and put them all into
earthquake
um and toki poner on the other hand is a
sort of minimal language that has only a
few hundred words
and uh i i'm sort of curious to to um
to communicate in in um uh in either of
these i mean i i think i i had the
opportunity to meet john kearner and i
was asking him you know can he speak
fluent ethquel well not really um and uh
uh there have been few people who've
learnt it um there's a strange story
about a group in i think ukraine that
had um
maybe russia ukraine that area um that
had uh
um i think this is a story that's been
been been told out in the world um
a group that had kind of decided that
they would take seriously the sap wharf
hypothesis about human languages that
you know the language you speak affects
how you think about things that
hypothesis is
you know still a bit controversial for
human languages in my world it's
definitively true for computational
languages that the the language you use
affects how you think about things but
in the human language case the you could
imagine if you use it quill which has
all of the kind of linguistic
you know wisdom of the world uh plugged
into it that if you could only speak an
ethquel you could think better and so
this group apparently uh had decided to
do that unfortunately they had some
other in a rather pythagorean way they
had some rather unsavory other beliefs
about the world and they were somehow
wanted by some authorities somewhere and
something that was all all a bit weird
but um that was at least a group a
rather pythagorean style group perhaps
that was learning ethquil to to better
themselves so to speak but i have i i
haven't yet i i really should should go
to one of these um events and and maybe
i'm not a good learner of languages
myself i i
maybe i you know i know that um uh at a
time i i learned kind of sort of all of
the computer languages that existed at a
certain time not so much recently
um and
i didn't i found that pretty easy but
when it comes to learning human
languages i've i've not been very good
at that
although i know that there are studies
that suggest that learning computer
languages is uh sort of aptitude that
that is somehow correlated learning
human languages which i find interesting
if a little bit surprising
um but in any case i'm not sure that um
i'm not sure how well i'd be able to
learn some of these languages
well i should probably wrap up in a
moment here but um i can just try and um
uh
oh some of the interesting questions all
right i'm just there's one mark c is
commenting what do i think is the
significance of the anti-thera device
um that sort of thing made of cogs
that's sort of an early astronomical
computing thing
i don't know what to think about that i
don't know i have to believe there were
lots of those i've i've always wanted
you know one day somebody's going to
find the antikythera factory and they're
going to find all the different devices
and you know i have this kind of
romantic view that perhaps archimedes
was somehow involved with that and
perhaps that's just because you know the
business i've been in in some ways is
making tools for things like mathematics
and um uh be kind of fun if i was in the
same business that archimedes used to be
in um but uh it's known that the
antikythera device had connections to
syracuse and the island of sicily which
is where archimedes lived so there's a
possibility that he was involved in some
way but yes i i have to believe i mean
the the anticoathera device
was
was mentioned in in writings by cicero
so it was sort of a somewhat known or
thing like that was mentioned by cicero
so it's probably
was those were things now why they
didn't develop further i'm not sure just
as as mechanical calculators as
developed by chicago and pascal and
these kinds of people didn't develop in
the mid 1600s
probably because they didn't work that
well and who could be bothered and you
know most people knew how to add adam
multiply themselves by hand and you know
easier to do that than to you know get
this brass thing and try and
run wheels around and so on so i i don't
know um
the uh
um
oh dan is asking have i read asimov's
foundation trilogy
and i have to say no
i was a
poor reader i mean when i was a kid i i
read tried to read some science fiction
and i
i i will admit that that was one where i
i was kind of a mission of a personal
um
uh
blind spot or something i you know i
read the beginning of it i just i
couldn't i found it really boring and i
just looked at the last few pages of
well what happened in the end type thing
which is just the most terrible way to
read a fiction book and um no so i just
haven't had the opportunity to to um uh
uh to read that and i don't don't really
know its story
um
okay that's right i'm i'm being told
dothraki is the language of the of the
game of thrones yes i that that that's
some
um
that's right
uh well okay i think we've we've got
some other
interesting
questions here
oh there's a question from sean here
just following on to something i was
talking about before
um uh
about
i was saying that the cellular autonomic
experiments that i did in the 80s could
have been done at los alamos why weren't
they
same reason
as these things i'm saying about there
are never jumps it's always walks
in the history of science
that is
the
you know you need to build up a
conceptual framework where there's a
reason to do such experiments if you
have a conceptual framework that just
says
you know why would we care about this
you're not going to do it and i think at
the time
the concept of
of sort of
models
where computation is at the center of
the idea of making the model just didn't
really exist
although i don't know i mean i suppose
they were getting closer to it um
the idea i'm sure
i bet i asked daniel lamb this question
and
sadly i i uh i certainly don't remember
offhand the answer you know
why well as i said he did try thinking
about one dimensional cellular automata
and he convinced himself that you had to
do some very complicated thing with
long-range rules and complicated number
theory kinds of things and i don't know
why i don't know why
you know he just didn't happen to do the
right experiments i suppose but i think
the main reason was that the conceptual
framework didn't exist that would lead
you to think that that might be an
interesting thing to do
all right we should wrap up there um so
thanks for for joining me and um
look forward to doing this and